let's take a quick look at using cloud
sequel with App Engine the first step is
to create a database go to the sequel
section and click create instance and
choose second generation give your
instance a name and then choose the
region and zone for your instance you
can now change the instance type and the
storage capacity don't worry you can
change these later if you want to you
can also ensure high availability by
creating failover replicas and you can
schedule backups and maintenance windows
as well click create and in a few
minutes your instance should be created
you can see all your instance details on
this page now go to the access control
tab and then go to the users tab specify
a new root password in your app demo
create an environment variable section
with the following information use the
instance connection name from the
overview page and specify a database
name and root password it's important to
create database and tables before using
it with App Engine you can use these
environment variables to connect your
cloud sequel database just like any
other my sequel database